in a Life Science and Tech Hub in
Bristol emofaron is working on new
vaccine technology to start up with a
great idea that could help change
medicine and it's not alone this is an
incubator for high risk early stage
Enterprises that need incentives to
survive the more robust r d tax credit
scheme for smaller they wanted more
generous tax breaks of research the
chancellor disappointed overall I think
underwhelming and this is a really
important part of the cash flow
particularly at the minute and a quite a
hard funding environment and companies
finding it quite hard to get money so
this was almost halved in the Autumn
budget and now we've come up close to
not the same as not quite where we were
I don't think they've done enough to
make us competitive say with the US in
in this regard it is risky you know that
a lot of these companies most of them
fail but the potential upscale is
enormous it increases the risk overall
and of something that's already a very
risky asset class
established Industries need help to
spark growth too this valve manufacturer
will open the spending Taps after the
chancellor announced every penny
invested in Machinery premises in it can
be written off against corporation tax
going up contentiously to 25 percent one
big area for us is to improve our valve
assembly repair overhaul and testing
Arena but that would take a significant
investment I stalled on just to see
what's going to be happening over the
next year and that's something now that
could be facilitated using using the
corporation tux reduction
this budget is an attempt to stimulate
growth and Stave off recession by giving
companies and consumers the confidence
to spend but after the economic trauma
of last year it feels like just the
first step to convincing business that
Britain is back on track
Brewers and beer drinkers will get a
boost with Duty Frozen on pints bought
in pubs but everything else Budweiser
sells faces steep tax rises in August
for the world's biggest Brewer the big
picture matters there is a finite pot of
money and if the UK doesn't have a very
business friendly environment when it
comes to taxation when it comes to the
incentives they're giving business then
other other countries will win out
it's still too soon for the chancellor
to tow success
Paul Kelso Sky News